dieses mal fragte kay aus dem studie von
der erste weltkrieg auch ein
sensationeller kanal wo ich jede woche
zu sehen bin und das erzähle was vor 100
jahren
während des ersten weltkriegs passiert
ist also unbedingt abonnieren und jetzt
faxe beckum markus von kanal markus
fotos und ich habe eine frage an dich
wenn wir auf der erde wie bei vielen
anderen vermieten zwei sorten hätten was
wir eigentlich anders wie wird unsere
welt aussehen
ich bin gespannt gute frage nächste
fragen würde sagen nein es ist ein
bisschen tricky aber die astrophysiker
gehen davon aus das leben so wie es
heute auf der erde besteht sich nicht
hätte entwickeln können wenn es zwei
sonnen gäbe denn damit sich leben
entwickeln kann braucht die erde eine
stabile bahn und die hat die erde nur
wenn sie um eine sonne kreist durch die
anziehungskraft zweier sonnen bestimmte
eben ein ungleichgewicht der
anziehungskräfte und die bahn würde sich
verändern das führt dann zu dramatischen
klimaveränderungen auf der elbe denn sie
müsste damit es ein stabiles klima gibt
um einen um eine sonne kreisen in einer
ganz bestimmten entfernung das sind
jetzt so 150 millionen kilometer bei der
sonne
und wenn es aber zwei sonnen gibt dann
ist dieser abstand immer anders und es
gibt ständig klima verändern und dann
kann sich eben leben nicht entwickeln
falls es aber sagen wir mal doch
irgendwie sich entwickeln würde könnte
der planet aber gar nicht lang genug
existieren denn durch die instabile bahn
um die zwei gestirne schießt er entweder
nach einer gewissen zeit ins weltall
hinaus oder stürzt in einen der beiden
sterne jack raiders germany ich nehme
mal an dass das ausgesprochen wird hat
folgende frage du wurdest ja gefragt ob
du zum mond gehen würdest würdest du
auch zum mars gehen ohne die möglichkeit
jemals wieder zur erde zurückzukehren
dort also leben und einen zivilisation
aufbauen also wenn es wirklich die
möglichkeit gäbe dort einen zivilisation
aufzubauen sprich wir werden in der lage
den mars zu tera formen
könnte ich mir das gut vorstellen aber
die bedingungen auf dem mars sind ja
nicht so
er hat ja kein magnetfeld deswegen ist
er ja ist eine atmosphäre ja in den
weltraum geblasen worden das heißt man
kann dort keine erde drauf machen
spricht man müsste sie in gewächshäuser
machen müsste das ganze künstlich machen
und da hätte ich doch die sehr große
befürchtung dass das nach ein paar
jahren nicht mehr richtig funktioniert
dass der mensch zwar alles sicher
minuziös plant aber ist dann noch genug
energie da damit die pflanzen wachsen
können und so weiter und so fort also
kann man wird wirklich eine zivilisation
aufbauen
ich habe meine zweifel und der mensch
hat schon so viele fehler gemacht und da
glaube ich dass selbst oder gerade bei
einem solch großen projekt dann so viel
fehler im detail stecken dass es nicht
gelingen würde und man wahrscheinlich
dort sterben wird und zwar früher also
wenn ihr auf der erde sterben würde und
da würde ich doch lieber jede minute wie
die mögliche minute meines lebens
auskosten
hallo ich bin tieren vom kanal tieren
und meine frage an christus ist wie bist
du auf den namen klicks umgekommen ja
das ist ja immer ein bisschen schwierig
im namen führen kanal zu finden und die
idee damals war auf jeden fall namen zu
finden der nur für diesen kanal steht
für nichts anderes also mich eine andere
bedeutung noch hat und
da mal lange drüber nachgedacht und
schließlich ist die idee so entstanden
etwas aus dem internet und etwas aus dem
fernseh bereich oder aus dem video
bereich zunehmend klicken klick und dann
zoomen zoomen clixoom so ist der name
denn entstanden und im nachhinein denke
ich mist weiß nicht so toll weil wenn
man den ausspricht dann weiß man nicht
genau
klima in schreiben soll aber
andererseits ist etwas sehr positives
weil inzwischen werde ich auf der straße
mit pixum angesprochen das heißt es ist
schon so was wie eine eigene marke
geworden und das ist ja nicht ganz
schlecht
ranger möchte wissen was fehlt dir im
allgemeinen in der heutigen zeit
technologie forschung und wissenschaft
ich glaube das entscheidende problem was
wir dringend so schnell wie möglich
lösen müssen ist die energieversorgung
wir brauchen dringend eine
energieversorgung die co2 neutral ist
weil da sind sich alle wissenschaftler
einig wenn wir alle fossilen brennstoffe
verbrannt haben da gibt es so gut wie
keinen sauerstoff mehr auf der erde
das heißt damit müssen wir aufhören und
da setze ich große hoffnungen in die
kernfusion sonnenenergie windenergie
energie aus wasser gezeiten und so
weiter und so fort
dass wir damit möglichst schnell die
menschheit versorgen und möglichst auch
alle antriebe dann auf elektrische
antriebe umstellen weil dann würde ich
ihr einiges deutlich besser
funktionieren auf der erde und wir
hätten eine rosigere aussichten in die
zukunft weil im moment sieht das schon
ein bisschen düster aus das würde ich
mir wünschen und das sollte möglichst
ganz ganz schnell passieren
daher habe mal fragte was weißt du über
die pläne der esa einer bemannten
mondlandung und was hältst du davon
ja ich weiß davon das ist tatsächlich
der fall die esa plant in den nächsten
zehn jahren eine bemannte mondlandung
ich finde das wahnsinnig spannend weil
ich glaube es gibt noch eine menge auf
dem mond zu erforschen und es ist ja
wirklich für uns interessant dort auf
dauernde kolonie einzurichten rohstoffe
abzubauen und so weiter und so fort
da bin ich schon sehr gespannt also
ich noch mal leben würde dann würde ich
glaube ich am liebsten astronaut werden
und eben mit zum mond reisen reisen im
weltraum interstellar ist ja ein
unglaublicher film zu diesem thema
gewesen
das video zu diesem film und der physik
im film das findet er hier und wenn ihr
fragen an mich habt dann stellt sie
unter dem video mit dem hashtag fraxinea
auf facebook natürlich auch auf twitter
aktuellen news und infos zum thema
wissenschaft weltraum und so weiter gibt
es hier in der app und im block und
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleib dran abonnieren nicht fest